welcome to and we have great so yeah
this car to take thanks yeah hello
everyone I want to introduce Karthik
which is a Python library for pocket
able management we built what this
exactly means will hopefully become
clear in a few minutes but for starters
my name is Florian eater I'm working at
blue yonder as as a data scientist slash
data engineer and I'm primarily working
towards setting up our architecture to
use these pocky tables to get started I
want to quickly tell you what our
company is actually about to get your
feeling about what kind of data we
manage so jje is our parent company they
clearly acquired us mid last year and
essentially they have a very broad
portfolio ranging from everything
related to logistics warehouse
management and so on we at blue yonder
managed only a small section of this
namely demand forecasts pricing
optimization procure optimization and so
on so what we do is we get our customer
data like some links think of sales data
stock state up your location for product
prices procurement information
information something like when can the
store order what amount something like
this and we perform machine learning to
make a demand forecast and in the end
perform optimizations such that there's
no waste no out of stock situation and
so on and so forth so what that means in
numbers so I divide this into two
sections to give you a feeling about
what our beta sizes so we get our data
submitted by the customer we refer to
this as our core data and you can think
about a mid to large or mid-sized
retailer of about think of a thousand
locations physical locations where you
have about twenty to thirty thousand
products or sk use that makes up about
twenty five million data points we have
per day so what we do is we perform time
series forecasts for twenty five million
times users every day if we talk about
parquet and in-memory data a data size
in park a file this is actually only
about a gigabyte but this is only
because there is very well very nice
compression algorithms and encodings as
we mentioned before and we usually store
two to six years of data so overall that
makes up a few terabytes of data per
customer we have but this is only one
one side of things because this is the
core data this is our input so to say
and what are we doing we are doing
machine learning so we generate a lot of
data garbage so what we do is we
generate about yeah a billion rows per
day when we do our forecasts or or rows
and so on and so forth which amounts to
about yeah in a panda's memory data
frame it's about half a terabyte of RAM
this is about the data scale we are
talking about and this is essentially
running in production every single day
so data engineering both efficient cheap
and easy is so to say a very important
thing for us to motivate a little bit
about what got us started to build an
alternative storage technology think of
a typical ETL pipeline you start with a
relational database you extract some
data you load it you perform joins which
are usually quite expensive but in the
end your machine learning application
needs flat data because that's just the
way it is then we process the stuff we
usually use some ore we use some compute
cluster in our case it's
ask which is why I will talk a little
bit about tasks later on but think of
something else like spark or something
similar that where you have a hundred or
a few hundred of hundreds workers
running on a cluster manager and in the
end they produce some output and want to
write it back to datastore and for the
simplest iteration it writes it back
just to the database and this is
essentially what we do at two or three
times a day per customer for various
optimizer or steps in our pipeline and
this is where the the issues so if we
scale this out about four hundreds of
workers we have scalability issues
because starting with the read these
joints are quite expensive so the
database which is working behind the
scenes actually has to perform a lot of
calculations there's the CPU load is
extremely high and the network is also
of course limited so the data throughput
is somehow limited we can maybe read
with 30 40 50 workers concurrently but
at some point it just stops unless we
scale up our database and this is costly
so this is the one side of thing or
things on the other side if we have 200
workers and every worker produces a
result how can I insert them
concurrently a lot of data databases
have something like a table up to manage
their transactions conflicts and so on
so concurrent insert is the difficult
problem for for typical databases and
this is where we thought ok we need
something which is cheaper because these
so we are using a distributed in memory
database for this one which is quite
expensive so we need something which is
cheaper scales better for eat and for
write and putting everything together we
are of course looked around what's
what's out there
and one of the things which come up is
the typical stupid so to say object
store typical cloud providers provide
think of the issue a blob store as s3 in
Amazon or the Google Cloud storage and
in a nutshell these cloud storages allow
you to store binary date
with a bit of metadata and that's it but
these blob stores are extremely fast and
extremely scalable when it comes to
concurrent writes and reads so there is
some some really nice baseline for what
we try to achieve and this is of course
not a new idea if you look around for
things like Hadoop presto and and
similar technologies they also use
object store so this is so to say a
natural starting point and this is where
guru take starts but before I talk too
much about kurtik I want to give you a
quick introduction about what task is
all about because for all of those who
don't have never heard of task or about
what is the computation graph this is a
very quick introduction so task
according to its own documentation is
flexible library for parallel computing
implies in a nutshell it reimplemented
the API of very common libraries like
pandas numpy tools and so on and offers
big data collections which are built
inherently for parallelization so what
it does it implements a collection for
example like a data frame which is not
built to run on a single machine but on
multiple machines so how does it do that
essentially it knows that my data is
partitioned in a certain way and if I
want to calculate something I group by a
sum whatever I can map this complex and
analytical tasks on much much smaller
tasks which are dependent on each other
and this is essentially a task the task
graph to ask builds for you and you can
use this task graph and let it run on a
single machine multi-threading multi
processing or you use tasks distributed
which allows you to scale this whole
thing up on a mezzos kubernetes caste or
whatever and have really full
distributed load and you can interact
with this data frame as if you look at
the entire memory at once so you can
work with terabytes of data in theory
although you only have very very small
commodity Hardware virtual machines
what this looks like for example here
this would be a task graph a very simple
one on the left hand side you can see
how one would build up a graph from
single computations and in the end you
get a task graph and what task can do
now start at the bottom with every
single task and work its way through
there until you receive your final
result if you look at more complicated
example in real time this is what things
might look like so you build up a very
complicated graph which might be a group
I over data frame and join between data
frames or something similar task maps
out which tasks need to talk to which
tasks and schedules them according and
this is all the magic does task does
behind the scenes for you and the API is
usually or supposedly exactly as easy as
you would be working with pandas
dataframe so with that in mind so we
have these task graphs and based on
these task graphs what can we do with it
we build caretake which is a consistent
table library management table a library
management library in Python so in a
nutshell if we very brief look at what
this will look like so we don't have SQL
we work in Python and this is about as
complicated as it can get because I am
using the full barrage of features we
have so on the left hand side you can
see okay I'm reading a data frame you
provide a name of store maybe some some
columns you want to retrieve and
predicates predicates think of them as a
where clause and that's it then you have
your task data frame you perform some
some calculations on it some some data
processing and in the end you store it
so storage function looks a little bit
more complicated but what's behind the
scenes there I will show you in a second
because that's the power of politic but
the API is essentially that you read and
write stuff and this is what color dig
is about at the very core of car take it
started with a storage specification so
the idea okay
I have a distributed data frame I have
many many partitions and I need to map
this onto a physical file system or not
even a file system but rather blobstore
which doesn't have in the notion of
hierarchical data so plain storages one
downside of these storages of these blob
storage that they cannot very
efficiently list you their contents so
it is actually a scaling problem that if
you have about a few hundred thousand
fires in a blob store to retrieve all of
your files so this is also a scaling
problem for for these prop source so
what kuretake does is it affects its
state in a metadata file so we have
essentially to simplify it we have
single file and this file contains a
list of all partitions belonging to the
data set and based on that very simple
notion everything else build around
we have Indic indices we have multi
table support and whatever bear is in
there
I will show you a bit of how this works
in a second but the core idea of Kartik
is to track your files explicitly
because this way you have essentially
only you have to do only once you have
to only read once your metadata file and
then you know what everything is then
you can plan your query and you can plan
your your data retrieval path without
looking too much into the to restore
ahead because if you think about the
performance for these datasets there are
two ground rules so to say the first one
is don't touch any file so if you don't
touch any file that's extremely fast so
if you read something which isn't there
don't look at the data
or if you look if you want to read a
subset of your data don't look at all of
these files if you have a few hundred
thousand files this is very inefficient
if you have to look at every single one
especially if the look the read goes
over the network
the second thing for performance is if
you actually have to look don't read the
file or at least not entirely and these
two concepts is essentially what
performance is build around and kuretake
is there to help you out to achieve
these principles so the first one don't
touch any files our system
what caretake does or what carry take
office as a feature is that we have
partition level indices so if you build
a data set you can essentially remember
all of the unique values of a column and
we might remember in which file they
this data lies so based on this if I for
example select value a of a given column
I know I only have to read five five
files instead of five thousands so this
is the first very basic but very
powerful concept of how to shrink your
data access this is called partition
pruning and this is possible for us in
essentially a constant amount of remote
cause because we have to read the meta
data file the registry so to say we have
to read the indices and based on this we
know everything we need to know about
how we plan our data access the second
thing is don't read everything at once
this is one of the core ideas of the
pocky file specification so we talked
about already about parking and I will
give you a very very brief introduction
about what Pocky is all about because
there's at least to my understanding one
very important feature one should be
aware of which is called predicate
pushdown how this works is essentially
that pocket splits your data into
several chunks so a very simplified view
of such a data storage file can be seen
on the right-hand side where we store
essentially chunks of every column in a
certain order and by this we can
calculate certain statistics which are
stored at the
bottom of the file so if I want to read
only a subset of the data I look up
where this subset of the data is living
in and then I only read maybe half of
the file or maybe only 5% this together
with the extremely well encoding and
compression things the park' thing has
to offer which boils down or compresses
your data about a factor 10 to 20 we
would use the network load sufficiently
fast that these excesses are quite
efficient in reality my pictures are
obviously not not really correct if we
look down below now at how the
specification looks like it is very
messy but this is just because we store
these statistics we store type
information encoding compression
information and all and so on and so
forth and as we just said nobody needs
to know these gory details nobody needs
to interact with arrow pocket directly
but it helps to know a few things so the
important thing is that there are these
statistics and this helps us to be
essentially extremely fast how does this
work
if you look at row group statistics
consider a very simple table two columns
an integer column a string column and so
on and I define a chunk size so I say my
row groups should be split every two
rows this creates two row groups and I
calculate statistics min max so I store
the minimum value of a given a column
and a maximum value of a given column
for every row group there's one downside
though if I for example want to read now
in this example all the ETA which where
a equals to my min max statistics don't
tell me too much so I still have to
access to row coop so I have to read the
entire file in this instance this is
where we need to sort the data and all
of the sudden if I want to create equal
to I only access this in a row coop so
essentially I can pull it on my data
access pattern to only a fraction of the
actual file and considering that no
matter no matter how fast Network is it
is always a bottleneck this is something
extremely
so with these two things in mind we can
look at what car to take to us it writes
and reads data so how does writing a
park a dataset look like and again think
in this scenario as everything a single
table you can see here would be data on
on a task work so they are distributed
so this everything works in parallel and
what I can do now for instance if I have
three of these objects I want to store
it then I what color take does it takes
your data and perform certain steps one
of the step is of course the first one
is passing the stuff but subsequently we
calculate all these important statistics
we calculate or we allow you to split
the files so there's one one feature
which is called partition on which gives
you a little bit control about how your
physical partitioning looks like because
as I said in the beginning touching as
you far as as possible as key to
performance so when you write data set
and this is just distributed fashion you
should be aware of how your data should
look like physically so the partition on
gives you the possibility to split your
data essentially on several files so in
this instance I'm using partition on on
the column a so every single input file
is split according to its by using a and
stored in a physical file which which
you can access also I'm calculating an
index information on maybe to column B
and in this case I don't then have two
indices which we can use to query my
data set a primary index which is on a
because I split the files and the
primary index means essentially for
every file has only a single value of
that of that column in it so all all
rows of a given physical file has only
one unique value the secondary index is
a little bit more messy you can have
multiple of these in a physical file
which is of course not not beneficial
but you
idea behind it you can essentially
calculate an index on every single
column so if you know
okay I'm usually accessing my data using
these two or three columns with an index
on it and in the end you maybe only need
to look at a single file and considering
that if your data set is a terabyte
large and you have a few hundred
thousand files this is quite quite
important for your performance I told
you before that quadratic so this is
nothing very special even tasks can do
this especially partition on there's a
standard feature of tasks but what
kartik office use the the indexing and
it gives you a little bit more control
about how the files look like so for
instance if you look at the bottom three
files all have the same value and this
is what Caltech offers you that
essentially it allows you to combine
these into a single file so it gives you
a little control about how your storage
layer looks like and this K this you may
benefit from this later on when reading
the data so you can engineer your data
set such that the application which
follows up as essentially perfect
performance but the whole thing is
hidden behind the scenes so reading the
thing you don't need to be aware of the
physical partitioning because this is
what chaotic does for you it affects
this whole thing and we solve the
indices and so on so forth
when reading this one very important
thing at the very end of this write
operation is the collected ASCII which
is named that or it's written there as
collect verify and and committed to data
set because this is something which is
rather special since we store references
to all of our files we can commit we can
perform an actually atomic commit where
we store where we set the state of our
data set in stone so even if your
computations fail if they are not it
important or if there is something wrong
with it
some integrity checks fail the commit
fires and this gives you data
consistency which is extremely important
if you run in
day-to-day production services so this
data said commit is one of the key ideas
of this data tracking and it performs a
few steps for once it stores the table
schema table schema is essentially a
list of columns a list of types and what
caretake does is checks that everything
you commit is actually consistent so it
doesn't allow you to store partitions of
different types or of different columns
because in the end if you read it that
wouldn't make any sense
and performs these comments if and only
if this consistency is actually
guaranteed and this is quite nice
because this allows you also to modify
this data set you can append that data
you can remove it you can replace data
so you can and this is something which
is not by default when you're using
France for instance tasks you cannot
simply grow it because if your
computations fail you read the data and
you're not sure okay
what's actually true here by tracking
everything explicitly you always know
the data you are looking at is
consistent the type stability service
also rather big to you if you've been
working with pandas as I assume you have
there are certain issues so for instance
in this example here I'm showing you two
partitions - one is boolean true false
true and the other one is a none so if
you would in your distributed
application try to store these two
partitions this would be rejected the
commit would fail why because if I load
it something weird is happening all of a
sudden I don't have any bull Khan's map
anymore
I have object cons and this has several
implications first of all it is unstable
sometimes different types behave
differently that's not nice
another issue is your performance
degradation is massive so if you have an
integer column for example or boolean in
this case and all of a sudden you're
using the plane object columns this is
performance degradation of maybe effect
of thousand if you want to do something
like krupa so data consistency is
extremely important especially if you
running your computations in a machine
learning stick your custom code you
cannot rely okay on a task does it group
by some it knows what it's doing but if
you run your own custom code and the
output is something which you store this
data consistency is extremely important
especially once you go down to predicate
push down when you need to compare
values on this physical layer this type
check is extremely important because how
do you compare a string to an integer
and so on and so forth so by having
everything consistently wrapped up this
gives you a little bit of breathing room
the table schema this is something you
already mentioned is something we use
arrow types for so we have in the end we
have all we support all the arrow tables
and we store this whole thing and park'
and read it out as i/o table which is
also the opportunity to interface with
other languages we offer for example our
using some c++ code which accesses this
data and by using arrow we can
essentially read the park' file
transform it and parse it directly to
c++ without any copy operation and this
is extremely so we've seen performance
increases of multiple factors just
because of things like these there's one
downside to all of this if you use two
pandas these types don't actually map
one-to-one but this is fairly
straightforward and I won't go through
this table just for you to know there is
some mapping and it's or not it's
sometimes a little bit different than
you would my would expect for instance
the date column there is no date and
pandas but yeah well that's that's the
way it is there are some downsides
as I said one of the very very useful
features which you can use this update
stuff so this is an example code on how
you could update a data set so consider
you have a database where you store
customer data and you have a parkade
table which is used by your machine
learning application so at some point
you need to synchronize this and you
don't want to download everything at
once or every day again what you only
want to do is maybe download just a
chunk for today or this week or last
week or whatever so appending to a given
data set is actually quite important and
this is the code how you could do this
so you write a simple function which
would be something like download data
from database and as you can see I'm
using table ODBC which is quite
efficient way to to load the data which
also uses arrow underneath so this is
fast and I simply loop over the dates I
want to download and create task delayed
objects and after that I pass everything
to car to take and the data set grows
continuously and if anything fails if
your data becomes inconsistent of some
type changes of columns change the day
at a commit where we check this you will
know and no silent arrows sneaked into
your system so what about reading the
whole thing because storing it writing
it is only the one side at the end you
need to read it because your machine
learning application or whatever your
application is wants to consume the
whole thing and as I said we don't have
SQL there are reasons for that but you
can essentially query a data set like
this at the upper left corner you can
see the retailer function where we
essentially provide columns and a list
of predicates so think of the predicates
as a where clause in this case I would
like to retrieve a equals two and B
equals B and C should be smaller than
0.3 and as I've shown you before okay in
this particular instance we have indices
so my indices without
any file tells me already that to read
this query I only need to look at these
two files on the lower left side because
both indices exclude certain files and
by this I can essentially create only
two chops in instead of 2,000 which read
the data the next level would be that I
actually read the data and that case the
predicate could push down comes into
work because for the one partition I
asked for okay
give me something with B equals two with
B equals B and C is smaller than 0.3 and
the pocke file tells me you know there
is not a single value well C is actually
smaller than 0.3 so don't load any data
but kuretake manages this that there
still so you get an empty data frame
essentially this is important because if
you want to combine these partitions in
the end a stable type system is again
very important on the other side you
retrieve a subset of the data because I
am using chunking I'm using chunk paka
files so I actually retrieve only two of
three columns and in the end I perform a
final filter and my end result is
essentially exactly what I created and
this is something if you cut your data
set from the physical partitions
properly and know what the application
downstream will actually query this
allows you to have you know sub-second
response times for small queries even
for really really large data sets so
about terabyte scale are depending on
how you slice and dice your data and
that's essentially it we can read and we
can write data and that's everything we
want to do and if we summarize this
quartic does nothing else than its
stores flat data as a perk a data set
but and this is very important this is
consistent you don't commit any data
which is not supposed to be there you
don't commit data from a failed run you
only commit what should be there we can
read very fast without any locking
mechanism we
using the blobstore using a three
whatever you wish to choose and this
gives you high concurrency so you could
think about
I don't know shuffling 200 gigabytes in
five or ten minutes over the network
this is what a blob store can do for you
that's the whole query planning if you
want to only select something very
special it's extremely fast because we
actually don't need to talk to the store
that much and the most important thing
is this is built in Python for pipe we
have the tasks API we're using the tasks
API we are very familiar with pandas and
the interface this exposes is
essentially a seamless integration into
the ecosystem so if you have or you are
a data scientist who's working with
scikit-learn pandas numpy and everything
else this is exactly the interface he
expects not so something like PI spark
data frame or some some weird other data
format but pandas this is actually
exactly what he expects so as I said
we're this is an open source project we
we've been working on this whole thing
for about two years and we open sourced
it only maybe two months ago so this is
why of the whole there is not much going
on yet but we are we released this as
version 3.0 which should give you an
impression about the stability because
we are actually using this in production
and we will continue to improve it so if
you feel like this might not be stable
enough well I might agree that certain
things might change but we are using it
in production and we have a very strong
interested interesting interest in
keeping its life and stable and working
so this should not hold you and of
course contributions are welcome so if
you are familiar with pandas arrow park
a task spark so the whole thing is built
in a way that we can essentially extend
it to other scheduling engines this was
one of the core ideas because in fact
when we started this whole thing we
didn't have to ask in our company but
something else entirely
so the whole thing is built with this
modularization in mind if you prefer
some other file format than parky which
I would not recommend but you can also
use that
yeah CSV ok we actually support CSV so
everybody needs to support CSV but yeah
that's it CSV and park' so far but if
you like to use everywhere something
like this there's also an interface
where you can just plug this in so this
brings me already to the end of my talk
last but not least as I said I'm working
at London I'm doing stuff like this I'm
working open source data engineering and
working with machine learning experts
all day we are looking for data
scientists data engineers front-end
engineer site reliability engineers and
much more which I couldn't fit onto the
slide so essentially if you have
expertise in anything talk to us write
an email or approach us on Twitter we
have currently two github accounts
because there's one for JTA which
acquired us and one for plunder we will
merge this in the future but so far look
at these one of the things you can find
that the blue on blue side for instances
TS fresh for for machine learning time
series analyzation or turbo DBC which we
talked about earlier so that's it for me
are there any questions
yep so I still want to get in there and
play with dust and jump whole again
sorry it was a slide get this one I feel
like running on this hole but it to the
last hole in binding me and I was so we
offer several interfaces so tasks for
instance has several collections like
the data frame a bag or some more
low-level objects like the delayed
object this example uses two delayed
path delay this is actually what the for
loop is doing and the delayed object
allows you to essentially build your
task graph on your own a different
interface would be that if you
manipulate some data frame because you
running some fancy large scale machine
learning or so on you can use a
different function and just throw your
task data frame in there and the data
frame is then translated into the
physical partitioning so there are
different interfaces for different
collections yep and ask a car to take
itself is not running on anything it
essentially just assembles to logic
which we need to do to have this data
set State in the end and the execution
itself is handled by tasks this is also
the reason why you can for instance
write a high spark implementation
because the logic of the individual
tasks is not not as chaotic so for
instance how to calculate and index how
to combine these how to commit a data
set this is logic we provide and we used
to ask only to plug these together to
allow the distributed execution and you
could do the same thing for spark or
something else entirely
[Music]
using instead maybe one morning because
there was yeah this is one example yes
where we can essentially have better
control about what's going on
bye-bye fusing these partitions or by
splitting them up building indices and
things like these essentially we have
better control about the performance
which which is happening yes so
performance should be better simply
because we don't have to look up all the
files if you call for instance tasks
read parquet which is also supported for
for s3 for example its first iterates
over all blobs which is painfully slow
to be honest and only after that it
assembles okay my my dataset looks like
this and then it starts planning and for
quadratic it knows this from the very
beginning so you have low latency for
query planning and I would dare saying
that even the read speeds and so on are
Bella I wanted to write the benchmark of
course because this is interesting then
I realized that task doesn't offer an
interface for the actual blobstore and
this is where all our data lies so this
is something I will prepare for my next
talk that I somehow put our data on s3
but this is of course something we
cannot just move our customer data
somewhere else so this I will figure out
a solution to that issue because of
course performance benchmarks are key in
these scenarios but trust me on that
regard
for instance alone parsing listing a
blob if you have 100,000 or 200,000 keys
this may may it take minutes 10 20
minutes
only only listing and this is only when
the scan start okay now I know what kind
of data I am looking at and okay most of
what I rep right now I don't need
because I have some kind of indices and
only then it starts reading stuffs all
the the latency the query planning the
scheduling is much much slower if you
use these
so to say on the fly pausing which are
done by a dark spark hive presto and so
on and so forth so yeah yep
so I've met estores essentially so this
idea of tracking the state of these
pakka files in a in a place which has
strong or fast Redux essentially the
idea of the meta storm so what car to
take does it puts this so there's no
need for this mater strong essentially
yes yes so the important point to take
away for me with Karthik is the Python
interface because if you use hive yeah
that's so there is something special
spark for instance could do the same so
it gives you more or less eponymous like
API and you can retrieve a panda's data
frame but you lose the consistency spark
itself also doesn't offer you
consistency Spock itself also has the
issue of of scalability of the blobstore
it also needs to list every single file
so you need something like a meta store
and yes we are using a chase for us our
meters so consider you have a batch job
which consists of a thousand jobs and
only and you want to use this data only
if all of your jobs are successful or
you want to use only the data of
successful chops because the job
my treat I for some reason and writes
the same thing twice so all of these
instances might introduce anomalies
because you might have duplicate data
you might have missing data you might
have inconsistent data types and all of
these things should be not an issue if
you use explicit state tracking are yes
potentially result results well it
depends on the error which is actually
there if you're missing data you simply
missing data analysis is incorrect if
you write duplicate data you have to
placate sin there if you have
inconsistent types frankly I don't know
what spark would do or if what would
happen probably crash at some point or
up cos the data which is also something
you wouldn't want to want it to do so
these are various edge cases which are
introduced by this lazy or by not
tracking the state explicitly and things
like at this example the update example
is something I'm not aware of that you
could map with simply spark or simply
task because how do you mutate the data
set and how do you know that this
mutation was successful if you do not
affect the state explicitly so if you
remove data if you add data and
something happens in between for
instance you removed half of it but you
append only a single file but you in
turn to append a lot more so you are in
inconsistent state in between so this is
something if you want to update stuff or
modify at this data set in certain you
knew new partitions we move on this
consistency and the state wrecking is
actually key
so since these questions came up we are
not the only ones in town because this
idea is also not very unique but we
started before this got open source so
this Apache incubating iceberg is
something which was released about a
year ago by Netflix and the idea is
essentially the very same they have a
storage specification which is a little
bit more sophisticated than what we
offer but essentially the idea is the
same that you store and track the state
explicitly because of various reasons of
consistency of constant query planning
time with reduce latency and they this
is something this is a tool which is
very well integrated into the Java
ecosystem so if you want to use hive
this is where you know what what you
need to do this offers you same
consistencies than Kartik does in the
Python world but for the Java world and
exposes this and offers the and offers
this for things like presto hiya Sparky
L and one of the things we would like to
do as car to take is move or evolve our
own specification in to be in accordance
to the iceburg specification because
this would also allow us to pass around
our data more freely between different
ecosystems but this is down the road and
there is currently not an implementation
all right so I think
over time so
[Applause]